il va falloir cadrer financièrement dans
la dans la CMP parce que il y a deux
impératifs je crois que la Commission
mix paritaire qui va se réunir mercredi
elle doit vérifier la pertinence si je
puis dire budgétaire du texte
encore une fois il faut qu'il résorbe à
l'horizon 2030 le déficit et en même
temps si je puis dire il faut que ils
permettent l'adoption du texte à
l'Assemblée au Sénat vous êtes confiant
sur cette commission mixte paritaire la
commission mixparitaire je n'ai pas de
doute puisque nous sommes majoritaires
donc
vous êtes majoritaire mais
c'est pas gagné pour autant
quels sont vos lignes rouges vont pas
les lignes rouges ça va être le point
d'équilibre ça dépendra ce que ce que
les uns ou les autres veulent mettre ou
retirer il y a des limites on peut il va
falloir faire des additions des plus des
moins savoir où on en est et le
gouvernement va nous dire ça ça coûte un
peu cher si vous voulez mettre ça voilà
je t'échange
on voit bien qu'il y a une pression sur
la situation des seniors pourtant était
une priorité au Sénat
notamment le CDI senior pour vous ça
c'est une ligne rouge ou ça peut faire
partie des choses qui seront mises dans
la balance moi j'aime pas parler de
lignes rouges parce que tout dépend de
ce qu'il y a à la place quoi je veux
dire on voit bien que il y a des
demandes qui sont faites par l'Assemblée
nationale qui va vouloir essayer
d'un stylet si je puis dire dans la CMP
des propositions puisqu'ils n'ont pas eu
l'occasion de les discuter et quand le
texte va venir ils ne pourront pas
toucher au texte puisque les conclusions
du cm d'une CMP vous pouvez dire oui ou
non mais vous pouvez pas faire
d'amendement donc faut que ça soit
préparé dans le texte de la commission
mixte paritaire ensuite elle ira au
Sénat puis l'après-midi de jeudi à
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est là où on
vérifiera s'il y a une majorité ou pas
pour voter le texte donc tout doit être
prêt dans le menu si je puis dire que
que présentera la CMP mais notamment
dans cette CMP la question des carrières
longues qui risque d'être discuté
puisque là il y a des divergences au
sein même de la majorité
de la droite et du centre entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat est-ce
que ça pour vous ça fait peu ça peut
faire partie des points de crispation
oui bien sûr on l'a vu déjà quand le
texte était soumis à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un problème interne
républicain il va falloir trouver
horizon aussi à l'Assemblée nationale
non mais clairement le gouvernement il a
maintenant des heures difficiles devant
lui parce que il doit s'assurer de sa
majorité
dans sa majorité relative on sait très
bien que un certain nombre de députés
légitimement comme ailleurs ont des
états d'âme parce que eux aussi ils
regardent par la fenêtre voit leurs
électeurs qui défilent ils se demandent
si il est bien pertinent de voter le
texte c'est la vie et puis ensuite
vous pensez que le gouvernement ne fera
pas le point des voies au sein de la
majorité entre Renaissance le modem et
horizon va y avoir des moments
peut-être après c'est le rôle du
gouvernement d'essayer de les convaincre
de voter mais on sait très bien qu'il y
a un certain nombre de députés je sais
pas ils peuvent être trois quatre huit
mais il y en a un certain nombre qui
s'interrogent certains l'ont dit
publiquement bon après il faut
convaincre j'allais dire ceux qui
peuvent apporter un appoint c'est-à-dire
le groupe républicain et certains
membres du groupe liote d'apporter leur
voix
bon à quel prix mystère et boule de
gromme c'est le ça va être la mission de
la CMP mais qu'est-ce que vous dites au
député les républicains qui ne sont pas
partis pour voter le texte
mais là encore c'est en conscience je
veux dire moi je n'appartiens pas aux
républicains j'ai pas de leçon à leur
donner mais je vais dire à partir du
moment où il y a une ligne politique
qu'on a partagé et qui consiste à dire
il y a une nécessité à voter le texte
bien sûr il faut le discuter il faut
l'améliorer il faut le négocier mais il
serait de bon temps j'allais dire de le
voter mais je peux pas être la question
est-ce que vous seriez prêt en CMP à
céder sur la question des carrières
longues puisque c'est ça le point de
blocage c'est-à-dire c'est toujours
pareil si vous mettez de l'argent pour
les carrières longues qui sont quand
même pas l'alpha et l'oméga de la
réforme ça coûte cher et donc qu'est-ce
qu'on prend comme argent ailleurs
si c'est sur les CDI seniors ça va être
compliqué
[Musique]